my guest today is dr marianne toopey who
wrote this book that has to do with the
10 global trends which we'll cover today
[Music]
to describe him in a proper way he is
the editor of humanprogress.org
a senior fellow at cato institute center
for global liberty and prosperity and
the co-author of the simon project he
specializes in global globalization
in global well-being and politics and
economics of europe and south africa he
has worked on the council on foreign
relations commissions on angola and
advised the central intelligence agency
cia and the u.s department state of
central europe thank you so much for
being a guest on entertainment thank you
for having me yes and you happen to be
from czech right you're checking
slovakia czechoslovakia so my best
friend when i was in germany
at a refugee camp his name was jan
staff
jan staff his sister's name was katarina
staff and they were from czech we were
best of friends two years we were
inseparable have great experience with
folks from czech good i hope i don't i
don't disappoint you no no i'm looking
forward to this first of all i read all
the articles i've seen you you've been
interviewed by everybody pretty much at
this point you've been on uh reuben i
think you've been on jordan peterson
you've been you've been ever obviously
you've been on tv as well but i'm
talking more to podcasters and some of
these 10 trends folks i'll read this
over to you
and then we'll go through them by
learning a little bit more about your
background so
uh
ten trends trend number one the great
enrichment okay
uh number two the end of poverty
trend number three are we running out of
resources number four peak population
number five end of famine six
more land for nature seven planet city
eight democracy on the march nine the
long piece ten a safer world so before
we cover these 10 trends would you mind
taking a moment
and giving us your background on how you
came about doing what you're doing today
well about 10 years ago i read a book by
a british author matt ridley called the
rational optimist and the book was just
filled with very interesting statistics
i didn't know about and i thought to
myself well um you know why don't we put
all of these very interesting statistics
online on on the internet that's how
human progress was born and then of
course once we started looking into it
we realized that there is a wealth of
evidence wealth of statistical evidence
showing that the world is actually
becoming much better along many
different dimensions of human well-being
and this is not well known at all in
fact a few years ago
americans were polled on uh
on on whether they think that the world
is getting better or worse and 66
percent of americans thought that the
world was getting worse only six percent
of americans thought that the world was
getting better in reality most things uh
that we will discuss today are in fact
improving and uh i'm not the only one
doing that a number of people have come
to similar conclusions harvard harvard
uh psychologist um stephen pinker
then of course hans rosling famous from
the ted talks
there's a wonderful website called
our world in data with max rosa from
oxford university so
people who don't want to
dwell in doom and catastrophism but who
are actually interested about the real
state of the world
can just go online and find out
about the real state of the world for
themselves so your major ba in
international relations classics from
the university of original cause okay so
if i was in height and then you got a
phd also
in international so you're this is what
you're this is what you've studied from
university of saint andrews and great
britain fantastic so i was always
interested in in economic history and
human progress is why
well because i always thought well i
grew up on the communism
where things weren't all that rosy um
you know and
then i came to the west
and i realized that uh things could be
much better and so i started being
interested in things like well why are
some countries poor why are some
countries rich and then of course uh
once you come to the west you realize
that a lot of people are very conflicted
about or rather are disappointed by
their stance of living they think that
somehow you know it is not good enough
and uh they complain a lot and then so i
thought to myself well we cannot compare
them to eastern europe we cannot compare
them to um africa or so on why don't we
compare western standards of living
today with western standards of living
100 or 200 years ago and that's what i
mean by economic history comparing
living standards today with those
preceded centuries or thousands of years
and then you realize just how incredibly
lucky we are and how incredibly recent
progress economic progress and social
progress is
so so would you would you by the way i
already just from the first two minutes
i got a bunch of questions for you but
would you say uh
uh
in communism people who live in my
families my mother said they're all
communists majority of them are
communists their bible was a karl marx
communist manifesto so if they grew up
in russia baku they thought stalin lenin
good people great leader strong leaders
right
do you think a citizen in a communistic
regime
doesn't even know what it means to
complain because who the hell is going
to listen to you like you know you can't
create a yelp and communistic regime
because you can write all the reviews
you want no one gives a so in the
communistic society they don't know how
to complain but in the capitalistic
society where there's so many
opportunities it's almost like the kids
are spoiled they know how to complain
because everything's been handed to them
easy life produces more complainers
tough life doesn't produce complainers i
think i think it's a question of freedom
of speech and freedom of association and
free media so uh take the
the extant communist regime today like
like north korea uh
a lot of people genuinely don't know
that they live in a slave state that is
you know 100 years ago a hundred years
behind the west uh they don't have
access to good information especially in
the rural areas in the urban areas
people may get access to clandestinely
imported uh
flash drives
that tell them about the reality outside
but you know especially in the world
before the internet and cell phones and
so on it was very difficult especially
in the poor rural areas of communist
world to know that they were countries
which are doing much better so if the
government uh propaganda apparatus tells
you all the time you are living
the life of dreams then some people
might actually believe it
but once
in eastern europe once true information
started filtering through uh through
vcrs and uh through uh western broadcast
and so on people started seeing what
life is real like in the west compared
to what it was in the east people
started complaining very quickly and
communism lost
all of its legitimacy and therefore it
collapsed
why why is it making another rise you
know last week i interviewed
we had an event at the vault called the
vault in
miami and we had about a thousand people
there we had dust and podia there we had
different speakers at billy being there
one of the speakers i brought out was uh
gary kasparov
and you know who gary
is the famous the legendary the greatest
of all time uh grand master chess player
who
255 months ago he was number one never
lost he kept number one for that
loss to a machine he lost to a machine
ibm which is uh called the blue one
what's the machine called the uh blue
something right blue uh anyways there's
something blue uh the machine he lost to
and there's some controversy with the
machine by the way that there was people
behind the machine that were playing
games anyways
but uh
he when him and i were talking he says
patrick just know if you ask me any
question i will answer
so you have to be ready do not ask a
question that you don't want me to
answer that's my kind of a guy because
i'm going to interview somebody like
that she said tell me about communism
and
deep blue yeah deep blue i said tell me
about communism he says well when i
lived in russia
everything was telling us how great of a
country russia is the greatest country
in the world and us is the enemy and all
this other stuff but the moment i became
a good chess player at 13 i started
traveling and he says finally i saw
capitalism when i saw what capitalism
produces i could not believe it yes the
fact that we are living and he says i
wanted more of capitalism not of
communism same here same here uh my
first visit to the western country was
in 1989 christmas going to vienna and it
was like stepping out of a black and
white movie into a color movie it was
the the the
the difference was that big 89 1989
communism collapsed in november 1989 and
we got to go to the west for the first
time as a family in ninth in over
christmas nights you know how i know
that you know why i know those dates
make sense because in 1989 july 15th is
when we went to germany at a refugee
camp and my friend jan staff showed up
end of 89 right because they were
escaping communism and we're together it
was albania was a czech it was poland it
was uh yugoslavia the old yugoslavia you
know all that stuff a lot of that stuff
has changed uh by the what year is your
birthday you're you're you're i know
you're 9 17 but you're 76 76 so we're
two years ago
when communism so you remember so to you
to you the way of living is communism
that's what you saw yes it was the
normal it was a normal thing and what
did the media propaganda in at that time
under the communist regime what was it
telling
uh uh the populace and what was school
like when you were going to school at 13
you're gonna remember what class was
like that's that's what that's ninth
grade or eighth grade 13th is eighth
grade right give or take seventh or
eighth grade so what was school teaching
you about czech and u.s and what was
media telling you about checking
the upbringing was very similar to what
gary kasparov has had which is to say
that the media was blaring at you all
the time about you know how everything
wonderful was you know we are constantly
meeting these production targets uh you
know and everything was rosy and
um and of course schools where uh were a
an apparatus of indoctrination uh one of
the reasons why communists were always
very keen on on
making their people literate
was of course that
it was an easier way to propagandize to
uh to
you know to to allow them to read in the
media only what the government won't
teach them to read in media but i came
from a deeply anti-communist family and
so the conversations around the dinner
table provided me with the alternative
uh viewpoint and
i i distinctly remember i was about 10
years old and i was walking from my
grandmother's house
down a down street which was you know
the main shopping mall in in my hometown
and uh you know in
in in communist countries on every lamp
post you would have a speaker that was
blaring government propaganda at you you
know for a few hours a day and as i was
walking by these shops which are
completely empty whilst listening to the
radio telling me how what a great
country i was living in and how we once
again met the four-year plan in three
years and things like that
i i did have a bit of a
bit of an awakening you know that that
i was living in
it was it was like living in two
parallel universes at school you had to
say certain things that were expected
from you but in reality um it was
obvious that the country wasn't working
the way that the government was telling
us it was what percentage of the
populace at the time was like your
parents who were anti-communists like
low-key anti-communist well loki in a
sense that you know personal
conversations were happening you can't
go to the public and say i don't believe
it precisely precisely um well obviously
it had to be high enough so that when
the berlin wall fell
in at the start of november 1989
people realized that communism was at
this point very weak and they all went
to the streets and the fear was gone by
that time by the late 1980s people no
longer feared
the state uh we no longer feared that
the result uh would be mass executions
and yeah it just sort of collapsed like
a souffle why were your parents
anti-communists like where did they get
their resources where did they get their
information um
from my paternal grandparents my
paternal grandparents were old enough to
remember the first republic before the
second world war and they remembered
that it was possible to live in a
prosperous and democratic country
czechoslovakia was one of the richest
countries in the world between the wars
so they kept teaching so so then why did
they stay why didn't they leave well
because you couldn't there was a there
was an iron iron curtain around
czechoslovakia you would get shot on the
on the border literally literally i mean
you couldn't get a visa to go to the
west obviously because if you could get
a visa to go to the west west
then everybody would leave so they just
put up barbed wire and watch towers and
hundreds of people got slaughtered
on the border trying to flee into the
west shot
torn apart by dogs electrocuted things
like that what was life like what was
fun at 12 years old what were you doing
well as a boy uh you know you don't care
all you need is a couple of sticks and
and you know play uh swords or or or
musketeers with your
with your mates or you um
go and i don't know climb cherry trees
and things like that it didn't really
matter i think the only thing that i
regret is of course never having access
to
things like western cartoons and
disney and things like that because of
course all of those were banned
yeah and western music which was banned
too fully
more or less yeah so if you got it it
was underground when you got it you got
it on cassette yeah which was which was
you know which was like recording
recording
with the quality
constantly diminishing this was before
digitalization well we got movies in
iran but you had if you if you were
caught
with rocky iv
you'd go straight to jail but we had it
and you'd watch these movies and
somebody would do the audio translating
translation and you would listen to
somebody doing the farsi sound of rocky
or somebody in whatever the movies that
we were watching when was that this is
78 to 89.
okay so out to there after the
revolution after this oh yeah yeah yeah
i was born october 18th so you got 79 on
so i get it yeah everything was very
underground you couldn't do it and even
alcohol bootleggers were all underground
you were public you'd win you go
straight that wasn't a problem in
eastern europe everybody was drunk to
get through them that was one of the
ways probably to keep people uh
distracted so going back to it you know
how they say democracy uh typically uh
lasts 250 years you you that number is
typically thrown around with 250 years
historically how long does a communistic
regime last is there a number for it
like you said it got to a point where
the regime got weak they could no longer
do what they were doing and then we
revolted against it right and then boom
things change
is there a timeline where how long that
system lasts i don't think it is
cyclical i mean basically what happened
the russia was taken over by the
communists in 1917 then because of
hitler's defeat thank god but hitler was
defeated and the and and the soviet army
marched into berlin and of course
all that territory which they covered in
central and eastern europe they kept for
themselves as their satellite states so
we exchanged one totalitarian regime
which was the nazi occupation for the
soviet occupation which lasted from 1945
to
1989 basically
40 to 50 years
that's how long communism lasted other
regimes obviously survive longer or
shorter okay so now let's change topics
you said 66 percent
of americans believe the world is
getting worse six percent believes the
world's getting better yeah if you turn
on the media the media is telling you
this is the most racist time of all time
this is the worst time to
you know things are terrible you know
everything is bad you know civilization
is not going in the right direction
why do you think 66 of americans believe
it's the worst it's been in a long time
well part of it has to do with the news
uh in a sense that if it bleeds it leads
right
[Music]
news is about stuff that happens and
what tends to happen are dramatic things
like airplanes flying into into
buildings or a famine or
you know what's happening in afghanistan
right now and those things tend to be
terrible
terrible things happen very quickly and
they are
they are easier to
to medialize
good things tend to happen on a
different time scale gradually over a
very long period of time such as you
know increases in gdp there is never a
time
a day or an hour that can that can that
can be on the front pages of the new
york times that okay overnight the
united states stopped being poor and
became rich these things take hundreds
of years and so um that's also part of
the problem good things tend to happen
over a very long time and gradually bad
things tend to happen very quickly
um
so those are some of the things why
people why people believe the world is
getting worse also
you have the availability heuristic this
is so this is basically how our minds
operate
uh it is the it is the dramatic which
gets the dramatic event that gets pulled
out of your memory file at a um
at a much more frequent
stage and therefore you think that
danger and horrible things happen in the
world at a must much uh with much
greater frequency than they really do uh
for example a lot of people get still
obsessed about terrorism whereas in fact
many more americans die by sleeping on a
wet bathroom floor but that's not a sort
of memory that you can pull out of your
memory file uh very quickly
those are just some of the things also i
think that it's probably fair to say
that we have evolved to be pessimistic
you see
if if you hear a noise behind a bush
you have
you can deal with it in two different
ways uh you can either proceed on your
way or you can run away well if you
proceed on your way
and there's a tiger or a lion hiding
behind it
then you are not an ancestor right uh
your genes get uh your optimistic genes
get wiped out of the pool so
an overreaction to a potential threat
such as running away is less costly from
a genetic evolution standpoint than
underreaction to a potential threat
say that one more time so running an
ovary and overreaction to
costly is less costly temporarily maybe
but not a long term right well in a
sense that you get to
you get to pass your genes on in the
long run whereas uh whereas under
reaction to a potential threat
is deadly can be deadly so the the
optimists get weeded out of the gene
pool the pessimistic gene remains and
it's very difficult for human brains to
cope with the fact that the world is a
much better place now because the world
has really changed only in the last 200
years so dramatically
can you unpack that so one of the things
you you said earlier
uh when we said 66 to 6 and then you
said you know most things have improved
some things have not uh and then we have
the 10 global trends that we can get
maybe this is the part as well what has
improved what has not improved
well almost everything has improved
economically
we are much richer than we were
we live much longer
many fewer infants die
between the age you know between birth
and and and year one uh we are much more
educated we go to school for much longer
literacy is much higher um
uh what are the other things um uh
there's a much greater supply of food
than uh than before
so economically um
it's it's unquestionable that we are
much better off we're also much better
off medically and scientifically and
technologically uh you no longer have to
plow your field uh you just go to whole
foods and buy something that was
produced you know on a large farm that
is
that is
you know tended to buy by technology and
so forth
but i would say that even morally we
have improved just consider sorts of
things that use that humanity used to do
to each other cannibalism gone
slavery chattel slavery gone um exposure
of unwanted children meaning letting
them die gone
mistreatment deep mistreatment of women
uh sure mistreatment still happens but
but
not to the extent as we knew in say
ancient greece and rome or indeed in
in the middle east in parthia where
women were basically
properties of of men
um so in a along all of these different
dimensions uh humans have also become
more moral our uh our
um
our homicide rates are a fraction of
what they were 500 years ago
we have fewer casualties in in terms of
conflicts when they do happen and war is
also on the decline but confidence when
they do happen they tend to result in
fewer casualties than before so those
are some some of the things that the
world has improved
what hasn't improved so so that part
great what hasn't improved
what hasn't improved um it's actually
very difficult to come up with something
i mean um you know a lot of people
believe that
the environment is not improving and is
going to result in a catastrophe now
the whole point of human progress and of
the book that i have written is to
is not to explain away all the problems
but to try to
convince people that we are not like
other animals
you know we are not like rabbits or rats
when there is a problem that we just
wait for for our
community or our our herd to collapse
when we have a problem we solve it we
are adaptive species so we can adapt to
changing climatic conditions and we are
also problem solvers so that we can
solve them
so you know
climate change is one thing that people
are pointing to and saying you know this
could be a catastrophic problem well it
won't be that much of a problem if we
can get
all of our energy or most of our energy
from non-co2 producing energy sources
such as fission or fusion nuclear
reactions
got it so the only thing that you would
say
uh is uh
climate change maybe the only thing that
we're looking at as an issue but aside
from that you there's not a lot of
things that's shown that's worse today
than it was before much depends on your
on your time scope so for example
freedom of the press is much better than
what it was in the 1980s but it is lower
than it was ten years ago okay we
included a trend in the book about
freedom of the press because
film of the press is still much better
than what it was say 40 years ago but we
have seen some retraction
yeah also when it comes to democracy so
the world is much more democratic than
what it was in the 1970s i mean you know
autocracies were here democracies were
here that has flipped but in the last 10
years we have seen some democratic
backsliding okay and that's something to
keep an eye on but it is still much
better than what it was 40 or 50 years
ago so
along all of these dimensions things are
really improving now
there is a caveat to this
when
the audience when the room is large
enough there will always be somebody who
will find what i think about as a
positive trend and call it a negative
trend
so
for example i would say that increasing
human wealth is a good thing but
somebody perhaps on the extreme
environmentally side might say
uh increased wealth leads to increased
consumption and therefore
greater climatic damage and therefore
that is bad or alternatively i might say
in fact i do say that education of women
is an unalloyed good it is a good thing
but somebody who is an extremist
religious person let's say a
taliban
are not terribly keen on on female
education as you know and they feel that
educating women is a bad thing so so
there are these outliers but
my definition of progress is a
definition of progress that 90 of humans
can agree on education good longer life
good um more money good that sort of
thing why do they have a bigger mic than
everybody else that understands common
sense why are they getting so much
traction today you told me you're an
entertainer well that's i want you you
understand what i'm saying
why are the people that are saying too
much wealth is not good and
you know uh 11 million people following
aoc so this is not good this is bad
because it's all about climate change
because the world is ending in 12 years
if we don't do something about it today
why is she
being heard by tens of millions saying
she makes sense why is he the taliban
saying woman why are they getting so
much credibility well first of all the
world is definitely not ending in 12 12
years of course
that's their presentation um i think
that um i think that ideas which are on
the extreme probably get more coverage
uh in the news on both left and the
political right um you know uh on a show
like this um or rather
on a much lesser show let's call it a
talk show on cnn
it is not really a good show or fox it
is not really a good show when you have
two people basically agreeing with each
other and
are congregated somewhere among along
the middle of the public opinion it's
always good to get somebody from the
absolute extremes who can scream at each
other and present a real contrast and i
think that is the key why
these people get more airtime and a
bigger mic than people like us that
makes sense simply because it's more
entertaining and we always like a good
fight even today that's why yes maybe
ufc is doing better than some of these
other sports because we're seeing a
couple people fight okay one of the
trends i want to talk to you about is
population right one of the trends
you're talking about i think is number
four
peak population the world population
will likely peak at 9.8 billion
at around 20 80 20 60. uh okay yeah but
at around 2060 and fall to
9.5 billion by 20 to 2100 is that right
um
so the best estimates we have right now
is so as you know there are about 8
billion people in the world today
and
according to landsat which is a
reputable publication um by 2100 there
is either going to be nine billion
people in the world or seven billion
people in the world there could be many
fewer people in the world
how are they coming up with that
well because we don't quite know how tfr
total fertility rate is going to play
out
so as uh wealth increases women get
educated and enter the labor force
they tend to have many fewer children
than when they when they when they work
at home
there's such a thing as opportunity cost
if a woman cannot make money in the
labor market
stays at home
then
well if she can go into the labor market
and make thousands of dollars or tens of
thousands of dollars i have a kid um she
is much you know she's likely she can
make that decision and in fact women do
so total fertility rate has declined
from about five in 1960 to about 2.4
today
yeah from from about five to two point
four now that's worldwide in the united
states about one point seven today today
now remember that replacement we're
gonna be in 60 but i'm curious in u.s do
you know what the number was and six
okay but we're in 1.7 today the world is
2.4 today 2.4 now the the issue here is
that actually a replacement level is 2.1
meaning that if we want to keep the
world's population constant we need 2.1
children per woman
to
to just maintain the current population
uh in the west we are already well below
it in korea south korea it's one woman
one baby per woman per lifetime so uh on
on so so you can see you can see the
issue there now
the reason why we included
population growth in in the 10 global
trends is because a lot of people are
concerned that we have too many people
in the world
that's why we have it however i'm very
ambivalent about this trend
because
progress economic
technological medical scientific depends
on ideas and ideas are produced by
people the fewer people you have the
fewer people you have to produce ideas
which then can reconnect or interact
with each other and then lead to
inventions and innovations so um you
know we could really face a world
in say 60 years time or 80 years time
that we'll have too few people to
maintain our current rate of innovation
and also to pay for all the commitments
that our governments have made in terms
of social welfare spending
so let's go back 1960 averages five
today is 2.4 worldwide yes uss 1.7
correct to stay flat you need to be at
2.1 correct but we're at 1.7 in u.s yes
so you mean to tell me
in u.s because we are a capitalistic
nation which is competitive competition
women are going to sit there and have to
make a decision at one point saying why
have a kid rather than working 2 500
hours per year like the average
competitor i can only compete at 2 000
hours because the other 500 hours i'm
having to raise a child and that's going
to take me back so they're going to say
i don't want to have two kids i'm okay
with having one i'm okay with not even
having a kid sure you're saying that
gradually it's going to go lower so are
you saying if we go at the space where
if if if the world is going to be at the
number that you said which is 9 billion
by 2100 either 9 billion or 7 billion
where is either 1 billion more or one
billion less than today than today eight
billion so either one more or one less
than today
where is u.s going to be for our 1.7
well very much depends on
immigration um i mean our population
still continues to grow partly because
of immigration got it and these are the
this is uh i believe that 1.7 is uh
citizen women people people who are
tracked by the census but there are a
lot of people who are having babies who
are not tracked by the census and and
and who are not part of the success
that's 11 million though that's that's
that's say 11 to 14 million
right you if you talk about illegal
immigrants that we cannot track
so you're not talking about immigrants
coming in because that's about 47
million right 40 to 47 million depending
on what stats you're looking at so
but if we're at 1.7 are you saying this
330 could go lower and lower and lower
it could go lower certainly if if
total fertility rate continues to
decline sure
the with the current trend where we are
have you have you or maybe you know
you're in the world so maybe you have
read uh papers on this have you seen any
papers talking about if that number is
going lower to the point if we're ever
going to get to the one or below one and
what that's going to look like in
america if we get to that point or no
i haven't read anything along those
lines i know that korea is an outlier it
has
south korea one one one
per woman per lifetime so we could
certainly uh look at a demographic
collapse
at some point in the future after 2100
population of the world could could
really go down that will economic
growth because it will innovation
and also remember that we have tens of
trillions of dollars of future
commitments uh to our retirees uh paying
down the debt and so forth and uh if we
don't have the workers to do it then uh
how are we going to get that money taxes
to be able to pay that off so we kind of
do need to
so okay uh so so is there a number to
uh help sustain economic growth
is there a number for that it's
i don't think about it in terms of
numbers i mean i think that human
freedom actually trumps even things like
population growth in other words i want
women to have as many children as they
want um
or none or none but
but and this is crucial i also don't
want americans american women american
american parents to be unduly influenced
by environmental extremists
and
people like aoc for example who
genuinely believe that women shouldn't
have
more than
one child or no child at all in other
words i want
americans especially american women to
make an informed decision about whether
they should have more children or not
decide for themselves freely without
being brainwashed
by the extremists who say that we
shouldn't really have more babies
well i mean then what that makes me
think about is
i don't know the stats but let's just
say if
if a uh
uc berkeley can house 40 000 students
per year just let's just say it's 40 000
students that are going through berkeley
and we know what berkeley teaches go
furthest left put berkeley put brown put
whatever whichever one those
universities but let's pick berkeley
every year
40 000 students are replenishing through
that mindset and that mindset is
capitalists are bad capitalism is this
it's a rich greedy people all they want
to do is this and negative negative
negative negative negative and they're
breeding these kids right the future
then you go to another school like let's
just say wharton business school that's
teaching business entrepreneurship all
that stuff if one school
has got only 10 000 students the other
one's got 40 000 students every year for
xing the growth that mindset like an
investment is growing it's going to be
very hard to compete so in the world if
there is a country that ought to have
more kids than anybody else to continue
the mindset of capitalism it's probably
got to be u.s but we're not doing that
so i don't know if i'm making sense if i
sound like i'm on
something well the the issue here is you
know you can extrapolate any problem
into the future and see collapse the
question is whether we are going to
change the way that we are looking uh
at higher education yeah now i already
see a lot of people like peter chill for
example talking about you know do people
really need to go to school to to study
humanities and social sciences where
they don't necessarily learn any useful
skills and may actually um
be brainwashed into believing in the
wrong stuff
so maybe
maybe the university model is
unsustainable partly because it is so
incredibly expensive you know the
reasons why i mean there is huge tuition
inflation because of all the free money
that is being or rather heavily
subsidized loans and so on um and also
um you know at some point um
americans may get fed up with the
extreme left-wing propaganda which is
being which is being
which is being taught at american
universities and decide that they don't
want to send their children there uh
maybe rather do online courses with
established mainstream academics um
all sorts of things could happen over
the next 10 20 30 years which will
completely change this particular
dynamic right now
what we are seeing is that even though
communism socialism had collapsed in the
late 1990s 1980s
marxists have retreated into
universities but they have carried on
their evil works
and they have carried on
educating uh future generations of of
pupils uh including americans and now we
are reaping the harvest of that yeah i
mean i've interviewed any of the top
communist professors in u.s or socialist
professors in u.s i've probably
interviewed them whether it's
uh you name them whether it's richard
wolff who's a
you know very open socialist or
asitar bear who's a openly communistic
professor in riverside community college
we like to interview them to kind of see
what the mindset is and how it's being
taught
i get it well it's very big of you
because of course leftists don't really
talk to people who don't think like that
i love talking to communists because
it's just a matter of time until the
argument doesn't make sense and you're
hoping it says well well well then it's
you know so then then we we the audience
can make a decision for themselves but
let me give you some other numbers here
i'm kirsten what you think about this so
is it
should we is it is it better for a
country to be younger or older so
younger more energy more innovation more
rebellious more pushback more
questioning
older a little bit more
the drive to compete is a little less
maybe
no longer wanting to argue every point
just doesn't even have the energy to
argue at every point thinking about a
different way what is the edge if you if
we look at historically the
societies that did very very well what
was the i'd be so curious you know what
was the average age of a citizen of a
country that was dominating at an era do
we do we have that data or no well i
don't personally look at it that way
because you know
i don't believe that sort of individuals
and their life expectancies exist in
order to benefit the state i'm thinking
about it you know does the state provide
the environment in which individuals can
flourish if individuals want to have
more children fewer children if they
want to live long
and if they can live long you know that
to me is a is a good thing what i would
say is that
more important than the structure of the
population is whether the country is
free
to
whether the people are free to
talk
to
think
to exchange their ideas
invent innovate try those ideas in the
marketplace have access to capital
those
i think are more important i'll tell you
a perfect design regardless of age
regardless of i mean i mean
yes regardless of h and i'll tell you
why
china
before 1978 and after 1978 china before
1978 already had hundreds of millions of
young people
but it was a dirt poor country gdp per
capita in 1960 was like 300 per year
right
why was it dirt poor is because people
were not free to do anything to utilize
their brain power to
grow the economy okay
today china is of course the second
largest economy in the world
why because the state has taken its foot
of the neck um of of the chinese people
chinese people are now have much more
freedom it's still a very authoritarian
country but it's nothing compared to
what china was before 1978 and the
effect of that is showing itself same in
india incredibly
young and incredibly um
a populist country before 1991
very very poor then come economic
reforms the country becomes freer and
after that india grows so i think that
freedom is more important than than the
particular structure of the population
but i think that as a general rule more
p people times freedom equals prosperity
okay so let's that
great point excellent very helpful but
let's put
10 countries
freedom to innovate freedom to do all
that stuff is at the same level yeah put
it all at the same level right
well
does age make any difference or still
not i don't know because i i don't know
but i doubt it because young people will
be more go and get her attitude you know
risk taking and so forth but older
people have more knowledge
you see old people have accumulated
wisdom which the young don't have and
that's also very useful we know where
innovation comes though
steve was steve jobs was in his 20s with
wozniak where zuck was in his 20s yeah
sure gates was younger you know musk was
younger so
you're very rarely going to hear a 57
year old start the next facebook as a
founder but all the people then run
those companies which these geniuses
start um because uh they remember i'm
talking about birth time about giving
birth right to me
i you know the whole who what came first
the chicken or the egg i'm talking about
who's giving birth to those ideas but by
the way i don't have the answer to the
question
i i am aware of the fact that when it
comes to fundamental breakthroughs in
things like physics mathematics people
tend to be on the younger side and once
they discover
something
they tend not to repeat
important discoveries later on in life
so
yes but there are other things that go
on in a society it's not just about
technological development there is also
things like for example listen to the
oldies
explain why
the world is not in a worse shape to
remember the cold war and the dangers
that emanated from the world right then
to have some knowledge about the
importance of institutions which you
have such as
democracy and
and um and separation of powers
you know young people tend not to think
about those things uh but they are
they're very important i ask you because
you got
the other that was looking at these
numbers
the average age of population in china
as of 2019 was 38.4 that's the data they
give us so maybe higher maybe lower you
have to trust the data that there's just
like they tell you their unemployment is
two percent right now which no one
believes that but they say the average
age of population china is 38.4 okay
u.s is 38.1 so we're not far off it's
not like oh u.s is such a young
population we're not right
then it goes india shows 26.4
yeah so china is 38.4 u.s is 38.1
india is 26.4 and they're now capitalism
they're producing great engineers these
guys are being recruited to the states
left and right because they produce most
of my software that i develop a lot of
the engineers that we use here from
state that came out of iit so i'm
wondering because if we if we look at
the
enemy of the state number one right now
enemy of the world right now country if
all the countries were one person
if all the countries were one country we
got 200 give or take countries that
number some say 191 206 whatever let's
just say we got 200 countries give or
take right
if all the countries were one country
and they were to pick
enemy the state number one enemy the
world number one
you're probably gonna see china be at
the top of the list okay
and i'm not saying some don't see us as
the top of the list
because of how deceiving you know their
alliances
most of the world doesn't want to align
themselves with iran but china does most
of the world doesn't want to align
themselves with taliban but china does
well
yeah
so so china's number one above all okay
i asked this question because to me i
think india is going to play a very role
important role to keep the world a
better place young big population
capitalism freedom they push back 100
apps 100 apps from china that they
didn't let into india so they're not
afraid of china to go up against them
some of these other guys are afraid of
them and i think china
they indirectly take a lot of shots at
india and the only reason you ever
take a lot of shots at a opponent is
because secretly you're threatened by
that opponent that they could do
something to you right what are your
thoughts about the future of india do
you think they're going to play very big
role the next 5 10 15 20 years i think
that you're on to something i think that
if i were to predict you know how the
next say 50 years are going to play out
in terms of economic growth i would say
that india is probably going to grow at
a faster pace
not just because their population is
younger
[Music]
meaning that more people are entering
the world the the labor market but china
very importantly is shooting itself in
the foot in two crucial ways
the most important way or rather one of
the ways
is the one one child policy which was
imposed between 1980 and 2015 that has
created a huge huge
hole in the in the population pyramid in
china
which is why the chinese now are talking
about now they had two child policies
now they are thinking about three child
policy and that sort of thing so they
shot themselves in the foot they have uh
they have
they have a lot of people who are going
to become retirees and they have many
fewer people who are
who are who are not there to pay for all
the things that the chinese government
now that's a scary thought by the
mathematical doesn't make any sense so
that's one thing the other thing is that
china is clamping down on freedom of all
sorts but intellectual freedom freedom
to think and speak and interact
publish
research and so forth
and and that obviously is something that
you i wouldn't expect to happen in india
because india has a long track record of
uh
being a democracy and having a rule of
law
need of need of which is obviously
present in china yeah as long as
a leader doesn't come in in in india
that gets voted that all of a sudden
gets close to utuji or china the world's
a safe place if
to me the scariest day
is when india and china are on the same
team i think that's the scariest day the
the world has to worry when india and
china are on the same page well
hopefully this will never happen yeah
well well
but the game that china plays
they are incredible at that game no
one's better at playing the deceiving
game today than china's not even us they
used to be the best
you know russia used to be the best
israel used to be top four best but
today
you know china is coming up in ways they
can do a master class on that and you
know and nobody would even be close to
them so that's certainly many of their
actions including uh what they've done
to hong kong was um completely
unacceptable i was hong kong was of
course
the greatest possibly the greatest
success story of the post second world
war era in terms of economic growth and
um they destroyed that but the world is
letting it happen
well uh there is very little that you
can do to a country of one point
whatever it is uh two or three billion
people and thousands of nuclear weapons
nobody's going to go to a nuclear
conflict over hong kong or indeed
taiwanese yeah i disagree there by the
way i don't mind having a disagreement
you can come back and you know say you
know you have the
i mentioned that phd have the public
high school diploma that's the closest
thing to people exactly fine but but but
for me
uh uh any time we underestimate an enemy
and they keep getting stronger and
stronger and stronger sometimes we
shouldn't underestimate them but it's
very important that
americans should also understand
that
there's a lot that we can do
to
get back on track
in terms of
american dream uh growing the economy
yeah having a strong country um
you know we there's very little that we
can do about what the chinese politburo
does
but what we can do
is to
is to alter our economic systems so that
it is not so heavily overtaxed
over-regulated so dysfunctional um
we can stop being at each other's
throats um and and things which which
make us weaker we can generate more
economic growth we don't have to
borrow so much money uh much of it is is
lent to china um you know we just have
to become serious about
our own country we have to become
serious about about challenges in the
future
and uh we have to um and we have to
change the way that right now it sort of
feels like
we are not very serious about our own
future it's as though we don't want to
have a future yeah to me it's more from
the school of thought of you know if
china's got 1.5 the world's got eight
six and a half billion against 1.5
take some of the countries that would be
on china's side give them another half a
billion okay let's put them at 2 billion
2 billion against 6 billion the world
still whoops their ass right so the
world's got to come together and hold
them
accountable and publicly call them out
it has to be very public about it
because at this point of the game
they're not slowing down they're telling
you we're going to come after you you
can't do nothing about it ever the
world's like i don't think they can i
don't think they can i don't think they
can in sports in sports you got two
things you got to play
historically the most exciting teams to
ever watch in the season are the
offensive teams oh my gosh dan antoni he
was a coach
any team he ever coached great offensive
team to watch the suns the leo we're
going to average 130 points a game never
won a championship right
then you go look at popovich
boring team to watch not the most
exciting team spurs to watch but they
won five championships in the last 20
years right
i think we have to have a balance of
offense and defense
and obviously as a capitalist i'm on
offense side but i think we need a
little bit more uh attention to defense
we cannot let this what happened last 18
months go away with us
not holding those guys accountable
because they'll do it again but also
remember that you don't actually know
how well
china is doing and how how much on
offense it is
um we don't really know what their real
gdp growth numbers are we don't really
know what their unemployment figures are
we don't really know about the health
of the chinese private sector are you
insinuating something are you
insinuating that they could have their
own market collapse potentially that
we're not aware of are you well i'm not
incentivizing anything i'm saying that
that that we have no id we have very
little idea about what is happening in
china in the same way that we had very
little idea about what was happening in
in the soviet union uh when the soviet
union collapsed it was a massive
surprise to everyone including people
who should have known better such as cia
what's the biggest difference between
those two way of thinking well uh that
the soviets didn't have a market economy
and the chinese had a quasi-market
economy now the the the important thing
is that china has much less of a market
economy now than it had five or ten
years ago because she is clamping down
on the private sector to the extent that
it wasn't done between 1980 and 2015
so so he's got this view of
totalitarian everything of of of putting
everything under his own control but men
are fallible
especially with men with so much power
especially men who have to make all of
these calls and if he makes the wrong
calls then china will suffer the
consequences oh i agree with you did you
see what george so this is very weird
when george soros did you see the
comments he made about china i did not
okay so ray dalio
uh comes out and ray dalio says
you know he's lowered his investments in
the u.s and he's increased in china and
he came out and says look it's mistake
if investors don't look at the
advantages in china's and we think we
need to make more investments into china
there's so many opportunities there and
ray dalio is somebody i've interviewed
before very smart my brilliant mind
george soros
not beloved by the right not beloved by
the center not beloved by a lot of
people maybe by the far left it's george
soros right
george soros comes out and says it's a
mistake for america
to do business with china it's a mistake
that dalio is saying that it's safe to
make investments in china because we
don't look at democratic democracy the
same way this is george soros saying
that so you know
some of the stuff that's being said
right now
it's it's almost as if she's maneuvering
and the moves he's making it's forcing a
lot of people in u.s left or right to
kind of unite and say look i may not
agree with you on taxes you may not
agree with me on such and such policy
but we have to agree on one thing
china's enemy the state number one we
got to figure that part out there's a
lot of things we can be divided on we
cannot be divided on the enemy and i'm
seeing that as a progress as a positive
meaning if she continues
to place cars the way he is i think it's
actually going to unite america more
what do you think
i think that we shouldn't
overreact
you know we have plenty of problems of
our own we have a 30 trillion dollar
debt uh we are running huge deficits
and um
um
i think that we shouldn't go and look
for enemies
unless those enemies reveal themselves
in a clear way such as al-qaeda did on 9
11.
so far
china has not to my knowledge
um attacked american vital national
interest
uh front line should that change then we
can have that discussion again that's
not their style though
that's not how they attack
they don't attack that way they attack
through proxy they don't attack that way
they don't attack like america attacks
see
america attacks hey you want to fight
let's fight let's use the better man
okay now don't get me wrong we've had
you know i've had the economic hitman on
my show who he explained to me in the
60s and 70s said they would go to
countries and say if you don't do this
we're going to put your country out and
we're going to do this this america
played a lot of games as well but china
doesn't play that game
china plays proxy wars it may well be
that forgive me you were saying
it may well be that uh
you know china also realizes that this
may well be the peak of its power and so
it does want to do all those things that
china won't think of that well
the chinese are probably operating with
much better numbers than than we have
they are seeing the demographic
collapse coming yeah uh they realized
they they they
made a lot of people in the world angry
which has contributed to um
undermining the trade relations between
the rest of the world and china they
know that by at this stage a lot of the
world is looking at them in a
in a uh
with a skeptical with skeptical eye
so
you know once again i just don't want to
extrapolate this particular problem and
until it becomes
unsalvageable it may well be that you
know 10 or 20 years time we'll be
looking at
this particular period in china as as
the height of its power i hope you're
right but a lot of a lot of people have
said that the last 20 years
and they've not been right they've cut
they've kept i had a
gordon chang i believe she was a
lawyer who lived in china for 20 years
and he wrote a book about the collapse
of china like 20 years ago or 15 years
ago none of it happened so i think
that's the level of optimism from the
right that uh
is
thinking they're always stronger and uh
kind of looking at the opposition as not
as strong as them i think that level of
uh too confident is how how it gets some
people to get knocked out you know you
mentioned uh
you mentioned about uh where china is at
and you know maybe they're starting to
realize they're weak
when you when you're the leader of a
country and you get up and you give a
speech that you know it's going to be
public on the world news everyone's
going to read it and see it and you say
if anybody around the world tries to
change our way of socialism thinking we
will smash their heads against the wall
of china
that's not you know seduction that's not
saying hey why don't we create under no
circumstances am i an apologist for she
all i'm saying is that america has to be
circumspect we have to tell them what
our clear lines red lines are yeah but
you know let's
let's let's not
let's not have a conflict with a nuclear
power unless we can if we can avoid it
yeah and let's not let them get stronger
than they are today because if they do
then it's too late that's that's the
part that i'm concerned about again you
know i'm just a businessman what the
hell do i know i'm just you know asking
questions here and i'm conducting an
interview so let me continue so out of
these 10
uh uh global trends that you have okay
we got a lot of them we've covered one
of them here
which of these concerns you the most and
which of them should we be most excited
about out of these 10 trends
and to remind you the great enrichment
and the poverty running out of resources
uh peak population
uh end of famine uh more land for nature
planet city democracy on the march long
peace safer world well let me take let
me take two because they're kind of
interlaced and that's uh that's
food supply and nature
so
since the birth of agriculture 12 000
years ago
people have lived on the age of
starvation uh famines were recurrent
throughout the world
uh often in very short intervals tens of
millions of people throughout history
have died because they didn't have
enough food
today
calorie consumption in sub-saharan
africa which is the poorest region of
the world is equivalent to what it was
in portugal in the early 1960s
we are producing enough food to feed
every human being on earth and have some
left over now of course we are not doing
such a good job of that because some of
the food you know gets wasted rots and
and so on but if if
if if the calories that the world
produces right now where
optimally distributed around the world
then no one
should go hungry and we can't we can we
can and and we are becoming more and
more agriculturally productive
if um
if the world farmer
if the average world farmer becomes as
productive in terms of food production
as an american farmer we can feed the
world and return land size the size of
india back to nature
say that one more time say it one more
time if if the average world farmer
becomes as productive as an american
farmer
then we can feed the entire world
and
return
the land mass the size of india back to
nature because we wouldn't need it the
problem right now is in many poor
countries farmers are not particularly
um productive whereas american farmers
are hyper productive we feed not just
the 330 million americans but we feel
feed
much of the world
not just that but food is decreasing in
price uh i'm not talking about the last
six months blip in terms of uh in terms
of
in terms of inflation i'm talking about
long-term trend
uh americans now spend something like
eight percent of their budget on food
okay whereas before sort of medieval
europe it was eighty percent of people's
incomes were spent on food today it's
more like eight percent holy moly and
think about it also this way um
the
the minimum wage in america the federal
minimum wage is about seven dollars
seven and a half dollars or something
like that yeah but 90 of americans bring
home 90 of people uh who have unskilled
jobs earn about 12 an hour okay
a costco chicken costs five dollars
right and that has enough calories to
maintain you for for a day that's two
two and a half thousand calories so
for
so an unskilled worker
a
a janitor
working on minimum wage
earns enough money in one hour
to feed himself for a day and has still
some money left over that gives you a
sense of how incredibly
uh how what an incredible improvement we
have experienced in terms of food
production and
going back to nature obviously
it would be nice if we could return more
of nature to
to
the animals
and withdraw humanity from nature
because because farming is the most
disruptive thing that you can do for an
ecosystem but the only way that you can
do it is to bring people into the cities
and to become more agriculturally
productive so right now people are
already doing things like
building
greenhouses inside cities you know in
skyscrapers using led lights and things
like that so i'm very excited about that
um
smart farming uh giving the plant just
as much water as it needs no more which
again doesn't waste resources
and instead of having to transport all
that food from from a farm thousand
miles away you can actually produce this
within within an urban setting that
would be cool too there are a lot of
things which humans are doing to adapt
to uh to improve to innovate and and we
are doing that in terms of food
production yeah you said something in
your book since 1961 the global average
population weighted food supply per
person
per day rose from 2196 calories
to
29.62 in 2017. so 800 more calories
a day
in roughly 50 years right 56 years
that's right now we're getting 800 more
calories but
i see some people in america they take a
lot more than 2900 calories and again
that's 4500 calories of
people so do we need to kind of get them
to redistribute the food they're eating
what we need to do is to understand that
humans have evolved to consume as much
food as possible because food was very
scarce and supply of food was very
uncertain
so one day you may
come upon a slaughtered deer or
something like that well you want to
munch as much of it as possible because
you don't know when again you'll be able
to slaughter an animal um
and so we have evolved to be to to gorge
basically right um and and people have
to understand that actually no uh the
fridge will be full tomorrow morning and
the day don't worry about it don't worry
about it cut those portions and so on uh
and here again i think that you know
people need to be educated about
not not in a sort of silly top-down way
but but explaining people
why they do certain things
not not not forcing them to pay extra
pennies for soda or something like that
but just explaining why you are doing
the stupid stuff that you are doing uh
may actually help more
so
that's a
good on the educational side we're
living in an era right now where a
little bit more of a force is
intact today in america over choice it
used to be a big choice country now it's
more force you better do this or else
that that that that we're kind of going
in that direction which concerns certain
people
but the one of the things we talked
about was uh uh oil oil uh
prices going up and you know what if it
goes up it's gone down now it's at a
point where the guys are making some
money texas people are making money
but you got some countries that are flat
out coming and saying look
by 2030 we're going to be 50 percent
electric cars by 2050 or 100 electric
cars u.s has come out and said our goal
is to be you know 25 by 2030. you got
general motors you got these cars are
manufacturers big ones are coming out
saying this the direction we're going uh
what's what's going to happen to oil
come 10 20 years from now what need are
we going to have for oil 10 20 years
from now well much will depend on what
happens in terms of other innovation
much will happen you know if if we have
finally look people are probably not
going to change their minds about
fission
which is unfortunate
because fission nuclear is a marvel it's
been around for 70 years it produces
plenty of energy without any co2
emissions but
for reasons which are difficult for me
to understand people just don't want
vision but if we could have fusion and
get plenty of energy and electricity
from from fusion which is much much
safer
than even fission reactors then then
then you know that that could be one way
in which you decrease your reliance on
fossil fuels such as oil
other things
breakthroughs in hydrogen
maybe even solar could become more uh
more
efficient than things like that so so
the future for oil doesn't seem very
bright
um and but but remember that only a few
decades ago people have been worrying to
death about about high stratospheric
prices of oil
and in fact just a few decades ago
people have been worrying about running
out of all sorts of
natural resources in fact that's not
what we are seeing what we are seeing is
that
natural resources are becoming cheaper
over time
and that's very counterintuitive because
because a lot of people still think
that if population of the world is
growing natural resources must be
diminishing and therefore becoming more
expensive that is not what we found uh
over at the simon project what we found
was that between 1980 and 2020
world's population increased by 75
percent but the prices of natural
resources fell by 75 there is a
one-to-one offset
every one percent increase in population
decreases the prices of natural
resources by one percent it's a very
counter-intuitive finding interesting
yeah it's a very financial country but
every one
increase in population decreases the
value of resources by one percent uh
decreases the price of resources by one
percent so what's happening obviously
is that you have more people
innovating and coming up with solutions
to to problems uh we are becoming you
know we
we save resources uh instead of uh
um you know
a a pound of aluminum now produces many
more coke cans than it did before our
cars are much more efficient just to
give you an example you know a ford
track in 1970 produced like 12 miles in
the city today it's 24 miles in the city
on what is it on a gallon or something
like that um
f-130 f-150 f-150 that's the one um so
uh so we conserve more and we're also
coming up with different ways of
we also
no longer use certain things which we
used before so
um
one way
i don't know we used to make candles out
of whale uh whale brains right a whale
fat we no longer do that we lose abuse
electricity we no longer use bird poop
guano in order to fertilize our fields
we now use
we now use uh artificial
fertilizer so there are many ways in
which in which humanity is actually
getting around the resource problem and
making resources actually decoupling
decoupling economy from from resources
there's a wonderful book which i highly
recommend to your listeners um in
addition to 10 global trends uh it's
it's andrew mcafee's uh more from less
and what andrew found
is that um i would recommend that you
have him on on your show what andrew
found was that um
truly sophisticated economies like the
united states and united kingdom reached
their peak usage of natural resources in
2000 and since then there has been a
decoupling going on between
between between economic growth and use
of resources so today
we are using absolutely not relatively
but absolutely fewer resources than we
did 20 years ago even though the economy
less resources than 20 no uh we are
using in absolute terms the tonnage of
copper and nickel right and and whatever
else is lower today than 20 and what it
was in 2000 even though the economy is
obviously whatever it is
higher i don't know right 20 higher sure
15 percent i don't know so there has
been this decoupling going on um you
know we are no longer dealing
necessarily with a lot of resources a
lot of a lot of wealth that is produced
in the west is in form of knowledge in
bits uh not in form of um
you know
physical stuff
let me ask this question did you say
from 1980 to 2020 the population grew by
75 correct
so so let me get this straight you're
saying the population grew 75 percent
from 1980 to today correct but you're
saying it's going to be around
1 billion higher or 1 billion less of
what we have today which is 81 hours of
2100 yes because does that make any
sense because the crucial thing is the
tfr total fertility rate which was much
higher in the two points in the five
yes because it was much higher in 1980
how what was that number what was tier 9
i can't remember what it was but it
would have been somewhere between 5 and
2.4 maybe it was like four
1980 tfr now i'm curious
because that is so so you've read the
articles where bill gates hey what's
your biggest concern right now 1980 tfr
was 1.77
whatever that number is so that
statistic if you see 8 1980
for us to double from 90 that's the
united states
so united states you have to put in
global okay
global tfr
fertility rates we can look at that i'm
curious right now to see what that was
in 1980
uh children per woman in 1980
was a around four
so 1965 1980 for today 2.4 and that's
how you get a 75 increase between 1980
and 2020. and that's why we could end up
with fewer people in 2100 than we have
now but let me ask you what did bill
gates say i i missed it bill gates said
the biggest concern he has is the
population growth so um i i i
respectfully disagree i i like bill
gates very much but i disagree with that
uh i'm on the same page as
musk
elon musk
he says that depopulation is number one
uh threat to humanity or number two
threat to humanity after ai
meanwhile he wants to go live on mars so
how does that make any sense so he wants
to hear
and start his own little community he's
probably worried about the ai so on the
ai part so let's talk about ai i'm not a
specialist on that i know i just want to
hear your opinion i i gotta i wanna hear
your opinion on ai and iran because you
had a couple things to say about iran
but on the ai side hey
you know where musk is with ai you know
hey we're eventually going to need ubi
because at one point and he said this
two weeks ago at one point people are
going to choose
to have physical labor or not have
physical labor so we're going to be
forced to have ubi
you know we're not going to have a
choice to do that do you agree with that
i okay so i started off being a
proponent of ubi i now have a slightly
different view on that
um because i think that
work is about
much more than just earning money it's
also about giving you a sense of meaning
in life and that's especially true and
that's especially true in a rapidly
um
secularizing society where a lot of
people
don't have religion i don't i take no
issue with that one way or another and
also
maybe
don't have families
you get meaning in life out of
three things three big things maybe
there are more but it's
family religion or work
and if you have none
then i think that leads to a lot of
unhappiness a lot of drug use or drug
abuse a lot of debts of despair and
things like that so i think that work is
important for giving people meaning in
life i'm personally irreligious but work
obviously fulfills me tremendously now
now so what i'm saying now is
sure go ahead with ubi but try it at a
state level
in other words don't impose ubi on the
united states
but as a whole try it at the state level
and see how it works
if
people get
more jobs if they are happier then we
can talk about it and we can see if we
can scale it up but in the meantime
let's start small and let's see what
happens yeah i hope they started in
vermont and just stay there and just
keep it there and not not come to any
other states the concern i have with ubi
is we learned what happened with ubi the
last 12 months
we gave a few trillion dollars of ubi
essentially when the money went out to
folks
and what happened the last 12 months
the billionaires became so rich that
they've never had this kind of money
before so the rich became richer
due to ubi why because you give money to
people that don't know how to handle it
they're going to go by products of folks
who run a business and they're going to
make their money money always flows to
the top that's my opinion i may be wrong
but i think money is always going to
float to the top so i think the rich is
probably going to be like yeah do upi i
don't care i have a net free money
money it's gonna end up in my pockets
anyway so the more ubi they do
the warrants and the aocs that money
ends up with the people they hate the
most that's just how math works now rail
kutzweil has a slightly different vision
of the future and the the the the
the people behind um singularity which
is that at some point in the future we
could have machines
doing all the work
and people own machines and
some people will own machines but the
point is that um
even then i think
some form of mental
exertion physical exertion some sort of
a goal will be very important because
people without goals without meaning are
not
you know it's it's it's not a good thing
i i don't disagree
you know anytime i've had too much time
on my hand
i dyed my hair orange i did some weird
things
the more active i am the more things i'm
doing the fewest dumb things i do for
whatever reason i like activity um too
much it's perfectly possible that you
know that's another i don't want to
order and share i'm just i'm not another
trend which we have is of course that
people are working less than they than
they used in high income countries
between 9 15 1950 and 2020 uh the amount
of
hours of work spent
fell by 20 so we have more time to
spend with our own minds
thinking about the many ways in which we
are
maybe falling short of our own standards
or comparing ourselves to other people
and when that happens
that's also a problem yeah you know in
1880 the average american works 69.1
hours per one-hour period yeah
today's 39 the the the city where people
work the most hours per week is a city
called plano plano in texas they average
41.7 for like nearly 42 hours and
there's some other places like that's
that that's 33 34 but they're at the top
last night you were saying something
about the shah with iran yeah and it was
an opinion it's not what you study and i
i'm not that's not what i studied we're
trying to make a small talk about of
course your your own background and uh
no we were talking about
the shah and where it went wrong and
then you had the islamic revolution and
you know we are all paying the price for
that in the sense that we have this very
ugly uh and repressive regime in iran
for the last 40 years i
you know shah was a modernizer
who tried to really bring
iran forward
i think that's probably
a lot of people who were very
dissatisfied with with the pace of
reforms right i mean you look at videos
from uh
um
from tehran in 1970s and you have women
with the western hairdressers and
miniskirts and things like that it's
unbelievable so there was a conservative
backlash but also it's not like shah was
a uh was a saint i mean there was a lot
of corruption going on especially
amongst the government officials um
savak the the secret police was brutal
but in no way as brutal as what we have
in iran now of course where they you
know string homosexuals from from
lampposts i mean it's absolutely insane
and so you know uh heroic failure
unfortunately
he
he didn't get us where we need to be
nobody makes that dramatic of a positive
impact in a country
with being normal it's just not going to
happen because they have to have a it's
a complicated individual you know who
the shah was
but it's another example of what happens
when a country makes such great
advancement
that people either become greedy or they
start complaining and what do the
complainers do
they bring the current iran that they
have and i'm in us right now because of
what jimmy carter did when he went to
iran
uh and jimmy carter's got to run for his
money right now because he used to be
known as the worst president but things
have changed
and he's probably sleeping much better
today because of the current climate
anyways having said that dr 2p thanks
for coming out folks we're going to put
the link below to his book the 10 global
trends
uh written by dr toopy link will be
below for you guys to be able to order
it and read it appreciate you for coming
out i really enjoyed this my pleasure
thank you very much yes interesting
interview which of those top trends he
talked about concerns you the most i'm
curious comment below i want to hear
about if you enjoyed it press the thumbs
up subscribe to the channel and if you
enjoyed this interview i i think you'll
also enjoy sit down i did with god sad
maybe two months ago we hit it off
you're gonna laugh you're gonna crack up
are you gonna question some things as
well if you've not watched it click over
here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]